had Chris screen tested and screen
tested and screen tested and and the the
head of the studio said she knew my work
and that she didn't want me to be in it
and that you know the reason was that
she just felt like that and this is a
quote I mean here we going back down
into the toilet that's okay that's
probably had a toilet on the stage yeah
yeah and she said he's just not and what
yeah I've been called that my whole
career and I just oh but you know thanks
a lot for that
so she didn't think you had the sex
appeal she did to guide the sex appeal
you know and I get it you know I
whatever it's a she's wrong Kevin but
you know the director and the producer
were nice enough to do another screen
test as a and they actually paid for and
it was back in the days when you know
screen tests had to be on 35 millimeter
camera and lots of lighting and
expensive expensive hair makeup the
whole they had to hire other actors to
do the scenes with me and they I tried
on a whole bunch of different outfits
and they they cut that together along
with some music and let me just kind of
you know bopping around and stuff like
that and they didn't even show her the
scenes she just looked at that and she
said all right whatever he can have the
part so I got I got that part but on the
day when I was gonna start the screen
test they had this idea that they wanted
me to have my hair different that they
wanted that to be in a certain kind of
style which ended up being a pretty like
that whole hair thing was like a thing
after Footloose with my hair spike yeah
yeah that kind of stuff and I'll never
forget I went in and they told me we got
one of the top hair dresses the top hair
cutters in the world and his this
haircut is gonna cause $1500 the day
we're going to pay this guy and what
year is this this is 1982 so that's
eight hundred dollars in 82 that's a lot
of money yeah I was like just give me
the $1500 you don't have to give me the
part I'll take the money I'll go home
I'm good yeah and I'll never forget I
sat down and the guy starts cutting my
hair and he had what one name or
something I can't remember isn't it
night all right and I'm looking at this
and I look up and he's got his eyes
closed and I realized I'm getting a
$1500 haircut and the hair cutter has
got his eyes blue
and it worked out though I got well
let's see the picture we think we have a
picture here that's the care cut
[Applause]